all right cool so
unless uh i'm gonna be talking about a
um
kind of a narrow but interesting problem
that we've had um
uh in the process of scaling up sharpie
um
so uh
to randomness in javascript this is
actually not my title mike came up with
this um i think it's pretty good title i
guess
uh i couldn't go up with the
better one so
that's it
um
all right okay so first a quick overview
of um of target so we are a real-time
analytics company um you
you can think like google analytics
except for um sort of two key aspects
the things that we measure are slightly
different and we also
produce uh displays on those
measurements in real time as in um you
know where we have an sla that says
something like uh if something happens
on your site within six seconds it'll
show up in your dashboard um in reality
when something happens on your side it
shows up in your dashboard probably in
like like less than a second or two
seconds um so this is an example of one
of our sharpie dashboards um just just
out of curiosity uh who who's actually
like
heard a tarpon or used charging before
all right okay cool who knows what the
difference is between sharpie and
sharpie for publishing is
it's like one person way back there okay
uh and who has heard of chirpy uh for i
think the i think the new product title
is sharpie for publishers with
advertising
okay as you really know okay so um
uh the
the the major difference actually is
that uh so shark beat uh proper which is
which is the the dashboard that you get
when you just sign up for uh
for the product on our website um that's
we kind of refer to that as like the
basic product and then there's traffic
for publishing which is uh which is more
tuned for uh for larger content creators
the places like new york times wall
street journal very very big sites um
for publishing also has like various
other features like um uh you send them
reports and things like that and they're
sharing for uh for publishing with
advertisers and this is a an advertising
product
integration uh in all of these cases
we're we're measuring kind of the base
it's the the same sort of uh basic uh
unit or basic concept i guess that's
that's of engage time here so
engage time is uh the amount of time
that somebody has spent on a page while
doing something
so uh specifically the things that we
look at are um have you moved your mouse
uh have you typed and people the screen
has your screenshot come
uh all right
um okay so um
uh and then uh all right so things uh
we look at um how much time you're
spending on on the page while you're uh
moving your mouse scrolling the screen
or you're typing these are all like very
strong indicators that you're actually
reading the page um and then the
charting for publishing for advertisers
product
does the same thing except that just
looking at not uh not the amount of
engage time on the page with the amount
of engaged time on ad units on the page
um so the advertising product is more
like it's more than of an optimization
problem we like we show publishers how
to uh how to optimize certain ad units
of things um whereas uh chart beat and
traffic publishing is a real-time
analytics saying this is more like a
dashboard and like pretty graphs and
stuff like that so all right so i'm
going to talk about um what's going on
in uh in the real time action here
um
okay so when you go to a a page
that is running chartbeat
uh what happens is um
your browser loads up this trip.js code
and we start sending what we call pings
to our servers
um
the normal terminology or the more white
accepted terminology i think is is a
beacon um for circle reasons we call
them pains so that's you you can see two
things right here you can ignore that
one for now but these these two uh
they're they're basically uh collecting
information about what's going on in the
page like things like uh how far down on
the page are you like have you typed or
moved your mouse in the last five
seconds um and it sends that uh it sends
that in one giant query string to
um to our servers
so this happens um
the exact time period between things
varies depending on what's going on but
generally it happens every 15 seconds or
so so when this page loads up um you
know in a typical session if you're on
the page for for one minute we might
send four pins to our servers and our
servers have to be able to
take those four pings um collect off all
the data and do something useful with
that
so one of the of the ways in which we
collect these things up is that um uh we
assign uh two unique ids to the pings
one called the ut and one called the t
key the tiki i'm not going to talk about
um it's it's um you know it's not
interesting for this top what the yuki
is is basically a unique identifier for
you on that site
um so so the uk is uh uh you know across
all of the people who are going to all
of our customers types of yuki needs to
be reasonably unique
so there are a couple of things i should
talk about here um
uh some uh some technical and sort of
legal limitations uh one is that we only
use first party cookies um this is for
privacy concerns so what this means is
if you are on um on the new york times
uh and then you go to the wall street
journal we can't link your activity
between those two sites up right so this
is a
feature for our customers
um
the
the uh the second thing is because our
code is being loaded up uh on all of
these pages
we we're on uh eighty percent of the
largest publishers in the us uh our code
is getting loaded up all the time it
needs to be small it needs to be fast
and it can't really affect uh the user
experience very much like we could take
down the internet if you know not if we
wanted to
but if we weren't careful um
so uh so the uh the truck.js code is
very tightly controlled and is very
small
and it needs to be simple and
understandable um a third thing is that
the uh the turkey the jsp has to work in
all browsers um we can't rely on any
sort of new uh newtangle features um and
then the uh the final thing is that
there's there's a
significant cost associated with each
ping here um we'd like to really
minimize the number of requests for our
server as possible right so the problem
then is okay how do you generate given
all those constraints how do you
generate a unique id for
uh for each user
um
so i'm actually curious
does anybody have any ideas
so let's let's talk about that um
unfortunately there's a lot of data
that's not available in the browser so
for instance the machine's mac address
is not available the id address like the
machine is not available uh those are
things that i mean you probably can't
even get the mac address but you you
could maybe get the ip address on the
server side so the uh the constraint
that we have that we don't want to make
an extra server call
um it limits our our our ability to be
able to use something like the ip
address on the server side to
to return uh
some ud
yep
publish a domain okay okay so that's so
that's that's very interesting uh we'll
we'll come come back to that in a second
um all right
the
solution that we uh that we happened on
is this um so this is like pretty old
code i think this might
literally be like four-year-old code i'm
not sure
um
so uh yeah so this is the uuid function
that we use it's actually not edu but
like a true ui
just call the uid function that we use
in the javascript so it's basically it
calls uh the random number uh function
and um
like squashes the result of the random
number call into an alphabet of 36
characters so this is like uh this would
be
i guess a through z plus uh it usually
plus the numbers
um and it does this 16 times and it
concatenates all of these into a single
string so you see you get some string
that looks like this all right so this
this relies on uh no information
about the user's history no information
about um you know about the uh the
machine's id address or anything that
might only
only exist on the server side okay so
this does this make sense
yep
so
uh a very useful question to ask here is
okay um yeah as sharpie gets bigger and
bigger we need to be assigning these
unique ids to a larger and larger set of
users right so let's say that we have uh
on the order of
1 billion users
given given this algorithm what's the
likelihood that we might randomly
generate the same uid for two users
okay so let's do some math here
so okay
we have an alphabet of
36 characters we have 16 characters
total so that's that's a number of
different uids there are out there uh 36
is roughly 2 to the 5.17 so
you can do some uh some you know
i don't i guess that's arithmetic or
algebra i don't know uh and yes
2d 82. i'm not very good at math um
so
2d82 which is roughly 4.8 times 10 to 24
possible uids out there
um
so that is
uh that is a lot of uids um
if we're looking at um
at a billion users i think the
probability that
two of these uids will will collide is
about ten to the minus five percent
so um here's the actual
probability uh function uh i think this
is correct i like did this while eating
lunch this afternoon so i don't know i
can uh if if anyone is interested i can
i can derive this uh later but right now
just accept it as truth
um actually i didn't know that this
thing was going to be recorded so i'm
actually kind of embarrassed that
there's there's probably some mistake
here um
okay so if um
uh
yeah so if we um if we have
82 bits um
uh we get a collision rate of 10 to the
minus 5
if we have 72 bits we get a collision
rate of about 0.01
so 0.01 is like sort of acceptable like
that's that amount of error is um is
smaller than
anything else in our system so you know
so we don't care
um
okay
there's a train wreck here um has
anybody seen the train wreck about to
happen
i don't think you know enough about the
distribution of the numbers
with that
we don't know enough about the
distribution of right numbers for that
function um
we're not looking for cryptographic
mobile security here bathroom is fine
for what they're doing right we are not
looking for actual cryptographic
security we just want random right
i'm sorry how are you seeding the random
ah
the seed so this is a very good question
uh it's undefined by the javascript spec
all right so i did some research on this
i pulled up this stack overflow page and
i was like oh you're in ie6 then like it
uses this method any of your 97 uses
that method and i just close the tab
because that's enough like i'm not going
to deal with that problem right so so
the seed is is a real issue um
so uh
typically what happens is the the random
seed for a uh
for random number generator is based off
of the time of day like the like your
your actual system clock
if you're lucky you get the um the
system clock in microseconds or
nanoseconds but most machines return it
in
milliseconds right
so if you if you take that and you also
you also take into account okay so first
off uh the clock in milliseconds is
typically say 32 bit value right so your
seed is 32 bits you're hoping to somehow
get
82 bits of like different combinations
from 32 bits that's not going to happen
right so at best you could get 32. uh in
reality uh if you're dealing with
traffic that's like you know that has
the potential to be slash guide for
instance right lots of people are going
for i don't know like date what's what's
like the new slashdot now um like all
these people are going to one page all
at once right if you you know you make
like a reasonable assumption that that
the clock is probably uh set for the
same day then you're not even looking at
32 bits there you're looking at 26
and if the clock if like all these
people are coming in the same hour then
you're looking at 21 bits right so the
amount of differentiation like really
decreases uh fairly quickly
so um oh and then there there's there's
some other problems as well like
um
uh not all browsers will reseed when new
tabs uh show up and stuff like that
there's a lot of variants out there so
it was uh it was actually it was a
little bit of a challenging problem for
us to like figure out uh exactly what
our collision rate was uh one thing i
did was i um
uh i i took that uid generation function
and i put it into node um and i just i
just ran it like
like 100 million times on my laptop and
check for collisions and i think on my
laptop at that time because you're made
with something like five percent uh i
redid that test recently on my my brand
spanking new laptop and the collision
rate was zero so i don't know what's
going on there but uh it could be it
could be bad or could be good i don't
know um
uh something else that you uh that you
have to keep in mind is the quality of
the actual random number generator um
and this this again is platform um and
browser dependent uh most random
generators are somehow
these days are based on the uh on on
understand twister uh not true of older
browsers um
older browsers can use like much
crappier things
okay so
uh right so recall the uh the goal here
is not necessarily randomization or
making our users anonymous the goal is
to identify our users
so
given that
um how many have seen this site before
one
all right you guys should all go to the
site right now because it will probably
mess with their data okay so so the idea
is this um
uh you can take a lot of the information
that's available to you um in the
browser to create an identifying
fingerprint um for uh for you right so
some examples of some information that's
in the browser is um
uh what operating system are you running
what plugins have you installed what
order have you installed the plugins uh
what's your time zone what's uh what's
your id address um
fonts right
so there's a very uh there's a very high
likelihood that you can um you can
actually
trace somebody to a single browsing
session using just just that information
so as an example i i did this this
afternoon um in my office on like you
know just a standard macbook running
chrome and the thing was
able to uh
identify me
um
you know i think that's kind of
impressive kind of scary i don't know
um
so uh let's uh let's let's run through a
few things here that might be of
interest
okay so these are things that we
consider
that could be sources of uniqueness for
users so ua is a user agent
these numbers are estimated
bits of differentiation or bits of
entropy
we just pulled these numbers out of our
asses i mean we have like no real real
basis for this and and what's more is uh
uh so if you go to the uh pen optically
site it tells you like how much um
uh how much uh differentiation there is
between like the various uh properties
of your browser uh those numbers might
not even hold hold in our case right our
our um our basic users might be highly
skewed like for instance um if one site
that's very mobile heavy right a lot of
people are using iphones um
there isn't as much differentiation
between iphones as there is between
desktops right if our user base is uh
mostly in the us for instance like three
time zones um you know we take the times
and information
uh you know for a u.s site that's not a
great differentiator but you know for an
international site that could be you
know like it could be more than two bits
it could be five bits or something
so uh so these these numbers were sort
of like hand hand-wavy estimates um and
if you if you uh if you take all these
numbers and you add them up they
coincidentally get very close to
82.
um you can mess with these numbers to
get that thing arbitrarily close to 80.
this is not scientific at all um ah some
something i should also point out uh so
uh so the document title and the
document path right well it might be the
case that there's a lot of variation
between the titles and a lot of
variation in the paths
given some title and somehow like
there's a very uh high probability that
those two are highly linked
right so
um so we don't get like the full
variation there um
another way of saying this is that if we
um you know if we called like for
instance the uh the time of the clock
several times we don't get more
randomness um
you know you you only get the source
once
um
yeah are there any questions about this
all right
so here is an example of um the output
of some of these properties right so the
platform string is really really long
the font string is similarly very very
long um and then you have like kind of a
mix of types of data like for instance
screen size color depth is three numbers
um the you know the the path is a url um
uh you know we also look at things like
um like the document width and and and
height as well and the page load time
those are all numbers right um
so uh we want our uid to be relatively
short and compact like a small a small
string so there's a question of okay how
do you how do you actually take all of
this data
um and make this thing into one small
short string
uh
there's uh there's kind of like a
a trick here which um which i think is
uh potentially overused but i love using
it everywhere um you just hash things
right so you can take like all sorts of
like craft loads of data just throw it
into a hash function and the thing will
output a string that's relatively unique
and is free from collision
i like that technique so much actually
so i i i just had a baby um and i really
like the name olivia but that's a very
common name my last name is chow that's
also very common so i just hatched her
name so
so it has a unique thing
to have 31.
uh okay so
um but here's so here's what we did okay
um
back to that uh
digest code size constraint um our
entire target.js code is around uh 9k uh
unzipped
uh but that doesn't minify right and
that thing is loading all the time
so we can't just
load in whatever hash function we want
the the smallest correctly functioning
sha-1 javascript function we found
was about 1500 bytes
there are sha-1 implementations that
claim to be smaller than that and the
regularly found one that was 500 bytes
in our testing it's actually we found
that is wrong
so we did a lot of like searching around
for uh for small for small things and we
can't load in a crypto library i mean
you know the um yeah i mean the
the size of that would just be too big
and then we also have to have this thing
so that it runs on all browsers um
so we can't use any sort of built-in you
know like the html5 crypto library or
something like that right
so uh sharpie loves to we love doing
internal competitions like like code
competitions and things these are all
like in good fun
so what i did was i suggested okay let's
let's have a competition um why don't we
go and invent a hash function this
sounds like fun um and you know uh it's
actually i think it's an easy problem
because uh i i decided you know through
cto fiat that um our uh our ups would be
160 bit uh
numbers i guess and when you convert
that into uh into something of base 64.
it's around 22 24 characters i think
um so you know let's just take 160 bit
target space you know we have about 80
bits like 79 80 bits of unique
information that we're putting into it
so taking 80 bits of data um and hashing
it into 160 bit space is easy i mean
that you know the 160 bit space is um
uh trillions and trillions of times
larger than the 80 bit space right so it
you know it should be it should be no
problem it's not crazy right so so i
thought okay you know we'll um
we'll we'll let the devs like work on
this for a couple of hours it'll be a
fun thing and then we'll you know we'll
have some beer and have a competition we
have a prize and you know
everything will be great
um okay so how do we um
how do we decide what hash function is
the best uh so the first thing is that
we we have a real world
input set um so the hash function has to
produce zero collisions on that uh the
second property is this we um uh for you
know for some of our applications we use
this uh probabilistic
infrastructure called hyperlog log uh
hyperlog logs depends on a property of
the hash function um in particular the
uh the hash function has to have what's
good what's what's known as good
avalanching behavior so basically it
needs to be very well distributed um the
intuition there is uh if you if you
change if if you have uh some input and
then you hatch it you get some value and
then you change one bit in the input the
resulting hash uh about half of those
bits should have changed from the uh
from the first half hash
if that makes sense um
and then uh you know if for all
solutions that uh that fit um you know
that past those two tests then the lat
the tiebreaker would be uh code size
um
okay so i thought this would just be
a few hours um you know and it would be
like a side project for the engineers it
turned to this like all-consuming
exercise um like people were like
coming up with all sorts of scripts for
uh for testing testing input sets and um
and like doing a lot of research into
like how hash functions are designed and
stuff like how hash functions are
designed is
uh it's magical um
uh it's like a black heart um you know
at some point
so you know
there was like one night in which like
four engineers like were there until
midnight just worked working on the hash
function at some point our vp of
engineering had to sort of like say okay
guys cool that you know so it's not
really
that um that important uh
so okay so i'm gonna run through a
couple of um of example hash functions
that um that we ran through this
competition
okay djb hatch
djb so that's uh
dan j bernstein
he is a mathematician and software
engineer
he developed a well-known piece of
software called qmail uh qmail was what
um or it is i think uh this thing that
backs the abu mail basically the middle
um
server
he invented this this hash function
which is very simple and very widely
used um
uh
one one characteristic of all hash
functions that i know is that they have
some some kind of an internal state um
sometimes it's one number sometimes it's
a vector of numbers it doesn't really
matter you know it's it's some state
that gets it gets passed through the
input and mutated over and over again
and then the state is the result of the
hash
so in this case uh he starts off with
this number 5381
he runs through every character takes
the ordinal value of the character
multiplies the hash by 33 adds it and
then adds the original value
makes sense right that's obvious
um this is a very simple hash that in
practice performs well right but you
might be asking um if you're a good
software engineer you might be asking
what are these magic numbers 5381 where
did you come up with that 33 what is
that for right zero oh that's so
suspicious
so um
a lot of hash functions have these
properties so this is this is what is
said about djb if one experimentally
tests all multipliers between 1 and 256
one detects that even numbers are not
usable at all the remaining 128 odd
numbers work more or less all equally
well they all distribute in an
acceptable way and this way you fill a
hash table with an average percent of
approximately 86 and this is like sort
of empirically tested on one input set
you have no idea
um you know if one compares the g
squared values of the variance i don't
even know what g square values are
houston
uh
so uh djb himself says uh practically
any good multiplier works i think you're
worrying about the fact that 31c he was
responding to somebody who changed the
3631 so that it would be a little bit
faster um it doesn't cover
any reasonable range of patch values of
c and d are between 0 and 35 that's why
when i discovered the 33 hash function i
discovered not derived the discovery of
the 33 hash function and started using
it in my compressors i started with a
hash value of 53.81
i think you will find that this does
just as well as a 261 multiplier
all right
this is also a very uh
a very common simple hash function um
full or no vote i think i'm pronouncing
that correct um
so uh
f and b is very similar to
djb except that uh so in djv you've got
um
sorry you've got uh
you've got this uh this plus right there
um what f and v basically does is change
that into
into an xor
um
for some reason that tends to make us so
uh right so that and uh and the
multiplication by prime uh tends to make
hash functions have a good avalanche
behavior
i don't know why i'm not a mathematician
so i'll just i'll just cross the
internet on this
okay
here is the current granddaddy of all
hash functions cha one right uh so this
is just a snippet of the main loop in
pseudocode right this isn't even real
code this thing is complex um
uh and it's got all sorts of magic
numbers right so for for i from 0 to 79
so we're going to do this thing 80 times
um sounds good right so for the first 20
times if we're going to do that with
that number for the next 20 times we're
going to do that and use that number it
you know it's just i i'm sure these
things like actually mean something to
someone who's smarter than me but to me
like it's meaningless like like my eye
sort of blends over this right you do
all this computation at the end you just
sort of sum them all up you perform a
couple of left shifts and that's the
answer right but somehow this thing is
like fantastic
okay so uh what happened was our
engineers uh they they did all this
research they looked at all these these
uh you know these well-known hash
functions and they generally um uh
submitted variants of uh of the existing
functions um we had some that were very
complex some that were very simple um
the best simple ones tend to tend to
look a lot like f and v so in fact this
this guy is basically v except that uh i
believe this constant is different and
there is no seed state it starts with
zero
um so so so this if you know if you care
about hash functions this is actually a
little bit suspicious you know that you
start from a zero c state all the time
in practice for our data set it doesn't
it didn't matter um
i would guess that if you are uh
if you care about these things it
doesn't make a big difference uh the
reason why uh so right so it turns out
that a bunch of the engineers submitted
solutions that passed the uh collision
test like they were refined for hll and
they produced no collisions um the
reason is you know so so we went into
the tie breaker and the reason why this
guy won is because the seed state
because it's all zeros made it just a
couple of bytes smaller than the next
best one
um
so okay so this guy one um
you can ignore all this this is just uh
generating a string from uh from that
value
uh so um we went through all of this it
was it was actually a lot of fun um
in the end uh we actually did not uh
use this solution uh we just used sha-1
all right what we did was we took we
took the
1400 or 1500 byte version of sha one
that we found and one of our engineers
sort of just like hand wrangled it uh so
that it was under okay i gave him a
threshold okay like well you shot one
it was less than one k
there should be a term for this like yak
shading or something again it's like i i
don't know like you know like orange
squeezing or
towel you know towel i don't know
so uh
uh yeah okay so uh he was able to do it
um he got this thing down uh to under 1k
uh and the navy's throne jesus
compression is actually it's it's a
pretty good um uh one reason why we
shied away from this and pitched cha one
was because our
chief
data scientist who's a little bit afraid
of like you know what if we invented a
hash function that looks good right now
but it's absolutely terrible in the
future and people will make fun of us
for doing this let's just use shot one
right it's like nobody got fired for
using shaw one
uh um very important question you guys
should all be asking right now is what
was the prize of this competition
um
this is an actual book
uh
published i don't know when like
probably like 40 years ago or something
first but
the most recent edition i think was
published in the last 10 years
let me show you a page out of this book
the book actually comes it's
really pretty fascinating it comes with
uh like the practice is an algorithm for
how to pick random numbers from this
book and it involves like flipping to a
random page uh taking one of these
numbers and then converting it into
another page number flipping to that one
and then marking columns if you've
you should be able to find it on amazon
all right so uh here's some reviews from
amazon it's such a brutal reference word
but with so many terrific random digits
it's a shame they didn't sort them to
make it easier
while the printed version is good i
would have expected the publisher to
have an audiobook version as well a
companion for one's ipod this guy this
guy was in the house and gave it a one
star review the book is a promising
reference concept but the execution is
somewhat sloppy whatever generator they
use is not fully tested the bulk of each
page seems random enough however at the
lower left and lower right of alternate
pages
and of course uh they're actually making
a sequel for the support
so um
uh
after after doing all this after taking
in all the sources of entropy and uh you
know uh squeezing this uh shallow one
like down to a uh to a manageably small
piece of code uh what's our collision
rate at the end uh 0.03 percent so this
is pretty good and in fact we don't we
don't even think that it's truly 0.03 um
what what happens is if you examine our
logs for these situations um
uh
it appears that that uh that pings are
being sent from uh from browsers like
multiple times like exact same thing so
we think it's legitimately it's when
there's a collision it's actually it's
the same user and we haven't looked into
why um 0.3 is small but it doesn't
really matter
yeah i thought there was a shaw too now
did you guys evaluate that yeah so we've
been looking at any of the uh the newer
shaw variants um
no good reason except that yeah you know
shot one is good enough and like the
reason why you might want to use the
other child variances if you care about
a
cryptographic um uh integrity and that's
something that we don't don't care about
yeah
um
so yeah it was just good enough um
uh so uh yeah so we've sort of gotten
this down to a
manageable level um
okay so that was my talk
um we are hiring of course uh we're
hiring not just javascript people or
people who like hash functions uh we're
hiring on the front and the back end um
uh some data signs decide on
the rear end i don't know
are there any questions
yeah do you guys consider just hiring an
expert that might be able to help you
okay so did we consider hiring an expert
to help us
yeah in in retrospect maybe that would
have been a reasonable thing to do um i
originally thought it was literally
gonna take every like everyone one hour
so
right like in that case like it doesn't
really matter um in the end like maybe
the cost of the time yes um but you
could argue that you know those
engineers were probably not staying
until midnight to do more work anyway so
maybe it was pretty fun
yep
yeah so if you're using browser
fingerprinting would it be a problem if
you're using clothing extensions to
randomize the strings um uh yes yeah so
that that's my problem uh more likely
though like like the the thing that
actually poses more of a practical issue
for us is if you're if you're into that
you might just be blocking javascript um
if you're blocking javascript there
isn't much we can do so um so i suspect
in practice that's not really a big
problem for us um what what is uh i
think more of a problem
like along those lines is uh lots of
people will have the um the most recent
version of the iphone like um
ios on the most recent iphone in which
case you'll get the same fingerprint um
there uh because we don't have ip
address or just like a rough uh proxy of
location
there the only thing that would
distinguish you would be um
would be like your time zone or
something like that one thing that one
engineer suggested actually is
you can apparently in javascript without
prompting the user um you can access um
orientation of the device
so like if it's tilted or not and maybe
we could use that as a source of entropy
we didn't end up doing it um
but yeah we might throw that in that
something just be fun
yeah
can you go
into a little more detail about the
issue with third-party cookies and why
couldn't you use yeah some marker on the
browser uh for basically generating a
number once and then reusing
yeah okay so the issue um why uh why
don't we do third-party cookies and uh
you know why can we just generate some
number one use it over and over again
so uh
the privacy laws in the eu are much
stricter than in the u.s so there are
two answers for third party cookies the
first is that the privacy laws in the eu
are stricter than the privacy laws in
the u.s and it's just easier to manage
those you don't ever use
third-party necessary third party
yes so we can set up first priorities
and and actually once we generate that
uid we start we store it in a cookie
either cookie or local storage depending
on what your browser capability is so
that the next time that you come to that
same domain you get the same uid right
so we do generate the uid only once per
user going to some site but we generate
a different uib if you go to a different
domain that is a customer of ours
because because it's stored in the first
part
yeah so okay so that's a good question
so can we make a request um
uh to a server that would then return
random information is that yeah based on
that basically something
yeah one of the of the routes that we
went through actually was um what if we
uh
what if we got our cdn to do something
for us so in this case it was uh akamai
um and we asked them you know can you
can you basically just run just call
uuid and like return to us somehow um
and they were not really able to come up
with a solution that was not
prohibitively costly
um so maybe they could have done it but
in the end like yeah like uh we just we
just we just can't afford it um the
second thing is is that it's um it's the
the way that our things work is that we
load in
an image um it's really difficult to get
data back through that image um i think
we have access to the return the http
return code right but i don't think
there's anything else it's not like
jsonp we're like executing something um
you know uh on you know we're not like
running some piece of uh some piece of
like arbitrary code that can just get
data
oh right so so there's also there's a uh
the there's a third there's a third
consideration which is that we we want
our our uh our ping protocol to be as
simple as possible we want to be able to
like once the page loads we'd like to be
able to just send the data off and not
have to
do one request to get the uid before we
can send the data off
there are probably ways for us to
engineer around that um
but
the way that the system sort of evolved
like you know that when charming was
small that random uid function was
totally adequate and then uh at some
point the target got big you know then
we had to go go and look at that again
and it was like sort of too much effort
to redesign the process
uh the mouse oh yeah okay so do we look
at the mouse pointer position to um
uh to as a source of entropy um i
honestly i'm not sure uh if we're not we
should be
well but you still don't get active
i'm sorry you still don't get iphone
which sounds like right we sold them
anyway right right so on the iphone we
still don't get the mouse position on
guys yeah um we did do things like like
page load time and stuff which is i
don't know kind of you know
an idea of like what's happening like in
the browser like when the thing uh
starts up but yeah
all right thanks